Next up, The Guardian is reporting
that we've reached a new era in our culture.
We are living in the time of goblin mode.
Okay, lemme explain.
(audience laughs)
Goblin mode is something we all have,
and we can turn it on and we can turn it off.
It describes those times when you completely
give to your most goblin-ish qualities,
and you enjoy it because it heals your soul.
For example, maybe you make a natural tray
fit for a family and eat the entire thing alone
while binge watching "Emily in Paris" season two!
Yeah, been there. (mmhmms)
(audience laughs)
Maybe you eat Oreos over the sink
in the dark in your underwear.
(audience laughing)
And maybe,
maybe you crawl into the same sweats every night,
having no idea if you've ever washed them.
(audience laughs)
Drew?
I wash mine.
Yeah, you do, yes, you do.
So, goblin mode?
Yeah, do you goblin?
Well, I've been known to goblin up some Doritos,
I know that's for sure.
(audience laughs)
You know, but it's just about being like gluttonous,
and what is the most gluttonous thing you do?
I like to spread some butter on raisin toast.
Ooh, keep talking, keep talking.
Yeah, some flower seed butter.
Yeah.
On raisin toast.
This is at night, I don't even turn on the lights.
I can do it in the dark.
Uh-huh?
(audience oohs)
And then I put that in a bowl,
and then I pour just a little bit of like popcorn
in the bowl with some hot sauce.
I crawl back in the bed, and I eat until I fall asleep.
(audience laughing)
That sounds so good, I'm gonna name it "The Zainab,"
and I'm gonna do it tonight as well.
(Zainab and audience laughing)
Count me in too.
That's like a perfect snack.
(audience applauding)
I love that.
All right, next up.
We love to try out the latest trends here at the desk,
and today we've at the hottest new snack on TikTok!
We have a "Drew's Review."
(audience cheering and applauding)
Okay, so, we love to get suggestions
from viewers on what we should try.
And today's pick comes from Hugh Connelly.
Thank you, Hugh.
He asked us to try mashed potato chips.
Okay, this is what's happening on TikTok.
It's exactly what you think it is.
Apparently, you boil potato chips out of the bag,
and then mash them into a paste.
And then you add in milk, butter, or cream,
and salt and pepper to taste.
I think it sounds like a goblin moment to me.
Yeah, right?
Yeah.
(audience laughs)
Okay, so, sorry, I'm salivating.
Uh-huh?
So, this is the, remember like Idaho Spuds,
and potato buds?
Oh.
Oh my God, the boxed potato.
I didn't know mashed potatoes came from an actual potato
until I was like 20.
Right?
I thought it just was out of the box.
(audience laughs)
So, this, it feels like kind of a,
I don't know some version of that?
Yeah.
Is that it?
I want it to be really good, right?
Well, one, two, three.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, ready?
Right, Hugh.
Aw.
Mm.
Yeah.
Y'all don't like it?
(audience laughs)
No, we love it.
Oh, okay, oh!
We get mad when we like it because then it's like-
Oh, mm!
Oh no, now it's gonna be a thing.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, this sucks.
Okay, so I-
(audience laughs)
And now, this is gonna haunt my dreams,
you know what I mean?
You know, what'd be really, it'd go great with?
A slice of raisin toast and little popcorn,
with a little sauce?
(audience laughing)
Right?
I thought you were gonna say a Thanksgiving dinner.
Ooh, that too!
This is good.
You know, I was watching JLo before bed last night.
(audience laughs)
In "Hustlers."
(Ross mmhmming)
(Drew sighs)
I feel like I could just watch JLo,
and eat this, and find my happy place in life.
(audience laughing)
Do you think JLo eats this?
No, no-
I, maybe as like a treat and a bite, and I feel,
I don't know, you know?
Well-
Well, you know what?
Even Jennifer Aniston, who I love,
remember, she just eats the one M&M,
and the one potato chip?
That, but that's what they what they get for it.
They look like Adonis sculptures.
Yeah.
(audience laughs)
You know what you get from like my lifestyle?
That.
(audience laughs and claps)
So, you know?
Oh my gosh.
It's a trade-off!
All right.
So, it's time to rate it.
What do we think of this?
Out of five stars, what do you give it?
You notice how I dipped the chip in the chip?
Yeah, I see how you roll.
(audience laughs)
You know what?
I would give it, mm.
I would give it a 4.5, is that okay?
Yeah, that's perfect.
4.5?
Yeah.
(mmhmms) Drew?
(Drew crunches)
(audience laughs)
I'll give it a 4.52.
I'm with Zainab.
(audience laughs)
Yeah.
That's good.
I'm gonna give it away
because I'm gonna eat it all, I'm so!
(audience and hosts laughing)
Get it away from me.
Oh, thank you, Zainab Johnson, watch "Upload" Season two,
now on Prime Video!
(audience cheers and claps)
I love you!
Thank you.
I love your story about your dad.
That's so meaningful, thank you for sharing that with us.
Thank you.
Live your dreams, honor your heritage.
Yes.
Thank you, Zainab, for that wisdom you dropped on us.
Thank you.
(upbeat rock music)
♪ Oh, oh ♪